[Music]
in smartphone spying news submitted by
the Grand Stand Siri is routinely
recording you and Apple reviewers have
heard some interesting things Wow I
heard that she's here and you have sex
and [ __ ] that's one of them well I don't
moan so I don't care
you don't make any noises not even
grunts well you don't like noises no I'm
just curious
most people make noises not that I'm
having sex with yeah but I feel good and
I'm unaware I feel like I just breathe
hard do you when you've only noises what
does that mean oh um for me I find it
really hot when it's like you're trying
to like contain your contain the noise
yeah containment like that oh yeah
that's why I like it when you put your
hand over me that's true yeah I met so
sexy that it's just like this is just so
hot but like I don't want no one to know
this is between us and this is like
that's time yeah so you like a lot of
Shh yeah I think she likes it when you
go like like sexy that's why you should
[ __ ] at your parents house and you
really got to be quiet or if you had
noise yeah I was about to say like I
think that's where that comes from
because I would have sex when like it
would be either in my own house when I
sneak my boyfriend in or I'd sneak into
his house and he had to be quiet or then
went ahead yeah I had to make sure that
he wasn't wake up so like I think all
that you missed the sneaky part of it
yeah yeah so when he's not home I'm like
anyway that's why Nikki once I have sex
in public in a dirty dirty dirty station
bag it's not one of the prerequisites
that's just adding on that that's the
smell like poop and man [ __ ] very
excited for it anyway so being at porta
potti so a bo epple series here they're
saying that those this whistleblower who
is saying that there have been countless
instances of recordings featuring
private discussions between doctors and
patients business deals seemingly
criminal dealings and sexual encounters
and so on
so is it listening non-stop is that why
it's so the thing that they're saying
here is mainly the Apple watch and the
home pod are the ones that get triggered
the most oh they hear things that sound
similar to like hey Siri
oh and it'll get triggered and then
that's was recording but hey seriously
is like yet such a common phrase hey
seriously though we're even saying that
one use like when media were talking
about Syria you'd get tripped up oh yeah
so I or even the sound of a zipper gets
tripped up what's fair DJ people with
lisps though that must be dope dude I
was in Nicky's office yelling at the
[ __ ] thing I'm like Google what the
[ __ ] Google goes mean you have to say
hey I didn't know that [ __ ] why set it
up like the nose I hiked up well I guess
that's pretty smart
yeah hey cereal but you know I'm dumber
than hell no probably lie better than he
was like I'm like did you skip the cat
litter and he's like yeah I'm I did it
he's like no I was about to like no you
weren't
because he tells me I'm gonna do it and
then and then he doesn't do it I'm like
did you do it he's like oh [ __ ] I don't
I get in trouble oh I did it
wow we have a good time yes yes this
whistleblower guy who was saying that
you know just didn't sit right with them
because he's like it was sad for all the
coke dealers that got in trouble for ya
know cuz the people should know and
there's also not a crazy vetting process
for these people that are in these
positions to hear this sensitive
material so they're just saying like
this is why do they need to hear it at
all aren't I aren't I just talking to
Siri and then series answering my
question or what
why does it go to national headquarters
yeah why is it being recorded so then
why is there a station with somebody
they're going so Apple is hiring outside
workers so it's like a third party kind
of thing from India around the world
yeah if you review Siri recordings and
grade held the software has responded to
the request so that's their whole
purpose is to make sure that like she's
worried so all those secret recordings
just get jumbled up in there yeah do it
internally then with people that you
hired for this [ __ ] don't [ __ ] do it
to your users well maybe no no no no
third they're not doing it to a group of
people who know they're being I guess
focus group yeah yeah they're they
should hire people and [ __ ] dwarf
Jimmy their song that way yeah yeah like
20 bucks or whatever like there's people
that yeah they're like sure yeah you can
record me barely pay me every day to
I'll be like hey Siri did this hey say
what about and at least you have a
there's a relationship with Apple where
you know this is happening yeah instead
of this [ __ ] that they're [ __ ] me
that's why the whistleblower came out
and said this ain't right yeah good why
do they do this person's a [ __ ] hero
just like Snowden and all these guys
he's a hero if they actually change it
exactly they're a hero for standing up
anyway because you can get fired in all
kinds of [ __ ] even killed maybe so then
Apple downplayed the likelihood it like
all of all this they said that less than
1% of daily Siri recordings get randomly
reviewed by its contractors to improve
Syrian dictation yes what less than 1%
of billion people yeah that's on a peep
[ __ ] very happy news though see they
have to take it twist it and then feed
it to why does that be random I can't
just be these people already signed up
to do it they can't even put it in their
little agreement like click here if
you're ok with this and I click here
well we'd all click it though y'all said
ok I think well a lot of the Apple [ __ ]
is like if you don't click OK you can't
use the [ __ ] yeah so it's not really a
choice it's like if you buy the product
and you want to use it you just I mean
you could be like alright [ __ ] this [ __ ]
I don't want to use it but all of them
do that [ __ ] I mean if we all danced it
and pans apples and then maybe we could
make a difference but we all on our
airdrop
we like AO drop okay people have to
think a little bit better like criminals
right like if you if you're all if you
aren't guard all the time about what
you're doing and like if you act like
the government's always like chasing you
then you have burner phones and all that
it's like thing you know you don't have
to worry if you make criminal [ __ ] look
better though and I'm in I get it
yeah burner phones are not sexy yeah
they're not but it's sexy to say you
have a bar neighborhood that they go to
don't look that safe not sexy looking
either
what's one a burr hoods I'll have to
think like a criminal not be one oh we
don't have to go into Boost Mobile
actually viable no but you'll know what
to be careful and donate yourself we're
not good at this Joe already making
other wrong decision we're gonna go out
to get a burner phone we're gonna move
to the ghetto
don't say we got to do this so that we
don't get recorded I don't think we're
made out for this [ __ ] so they are
saying that you can just disable serial
together which is what I do that [ __ ]
hate that [ __ ] how do you do that you
just go in your settings in disable Siri
yeah they're for my watch for my laptop
and my phone of myself listen to be
really safe though if we do that I think
it's still recording I think it's still
recording here well then the
whistleblower is saying that it's being
tripped up when you're trying to use it
so if you're disabling it it won't be
recording you yeah that's the idea
you use the only person I know that use
it I love Siri but I hate that she's
listening to my [ __ ] what do you do with
Siri all the time I just don't ever have
to Siri call my wife see your call my
wife's ear call my mom and it's easier
tripping the brain is easier than all
this [ __ ] shooting up skull and maybe
you're driving or something and her name
is under my wife yeah oh I never use it
so when I call it says he goes my wife
is calling yeah
wait do you have carplay on your in your
car no key complains dizzy cuz he has to
connect to I have only four phone I
can't could do music through it what I
bought my car one year before the
[ __ ] Revolution why can't you play
music
exactly exactly don't [ __ ] tense
sing cuz I know I have that but it
doesn't work well it doesn't do music
that's weird
really weird when we talk about how a
little my dick is all rather Jesus
humiliated you can see you might watch
Go Go Ahead lie about it shut the [ __ ]
up I know what we need to get up is is
the tape that connects with the wire
that you could plug inside your [ __ ]
you plug it into your CD player yeah
[Laughter]
you're one of those chumps all were
paying for a Tesla so whatever those
he's also paying for it so you wanted
the car I did notice that you got one
after TIF Co I did because I love her
and I think she's so [ __ ] cool I want
to copy everything that she does yeah
but you didn't just copy it you got the
better one I'm watching you convinced
that stuff cuz we sat in oh [ __ ] it's
pretty tight credit she was selling me
on it when she picks me up for urban
officer you're calling your wife that's
the same thing yeah so dope it's like
I'm in the future yeah it is pretty sick
our friends have one too so you abandon
ship that [ __ ] fast no no no paying
all the [ __ ] yeah he's a kind of person
that looks it really goes I want that
I'm gonna buy it cuz it's not the deal
then he buys like a random car that
doesn't have music show me the deal on
Tesla okay I'll be a hundred [ __ ]
[ __ ] tax break
Yeah right but you're still paying
[ __ ] 115 or whatever for it's crazy
yeah so that's it for a car I'm paying
that [ __ ] to come good day to be how do
you have to put gas in that [ __ ]
I know that's pretty cool
but you also can't you know if we wanted
to have a race and go 300 miles and
you're [ __ ] I'm pretty fast you
[ __ ]
no no no you literally can't go 300
miles on the [ __ ] show I can you're
right your car's better your car's
better than how much does it cost to
fill up your tank I did it this morning
for $48 you know how much it costs for
me how much 0:14 yeah but how much are
you paying in power bro to charge you go
to the supercharger now they started
charging I have are you giving up right
now just paid 14 bucks to charge a car
yeah fully fully charge it how long does
it take I don't know how long did that
see how minutes how come already five
minutes and then how much are you paying
a month for the car yeah but exactly
[ __ ] good luck to you the savings are
unbelievable you know what we fit in our
[ __ ] cars my car like that you've
never sat in a Mini Cooper then because
mommy it's actually pretty roomy yeah I
can't because it only sits two people
when they talk they tell you sits for it
sits for as long as there's not a
lobster costume in the back for four
years then it sits for there's a costume
back there four years going now why do
you have those costumes I bet you the
top of it is pink like this acknowledge
it so then he like unfolded like beet
bread and then just yeah I forget that
you have a car sometimes are fun to
drive cutest bug we cut it before I say
nice [ __ ] cut it before I say my [ __ ]
they're really cool Sean
[Music]
you
[Music]